okay and then he talks about negotiation
there's an entire episode
in the series on negotiation he really
likes the idea of men and women
negotiating their differences
I don't like that term negotiating
um what is it actual definition
the dictionary definition as it would
stand uh discussion aimed at reaching an
agreement
that's really all that it boils down to
so in the context of the English
language he's basically saying
aim at reaching an agreement with your
differences with the topic of
negotiation and look
there's certain things that you're going
to have to have discussions with in a
long-term relationship like I've said
before I'm in an LTR I've been there for
some time now and there are
conversations in my relationship but I
don't play games I don't uh like again I
wrote the book I'm the unplugged Alpha
right I don't do the we're on we're on
equal footing men and women are the same
egalitarian [ __ ] I'm the man I lead
she's a woman she's a feminine she
follows she enters my frame that's the
way it's going to be and if it's not
that way I'm not having it
um so I guess I'm like you know again
back to the point of women that submit
to men I guess I'm a tyrannical slave
driver by his definition but I suppose
that's just me and I would I would aim
to argue that my relationship again I
haven't been I've been with her for 33
years or whatever the hell he's been
with her uh with Tammy for uh but I
would aim that my relationship is far
far better than any nonsense that he's I
mean I certainly don't [ __ ] cry when
it comes to thinking about things like
um discussions around cheating obviously
somebody either him or very close to him
was betrayed by a woman
um it says logos logos guided
negotiation is a solution it says you
negotiate every single thing in a
household and this is where he gets them
as a [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
where the scissors go in the appliance
drawer how every single room in the
house is set up now look
I don't live in my LTR
but
if in the future I so choose to do so I
would not give a flying [ __ ] where the
scissors go in the appliance drawer okay
I would not care how each room is set up
provided that my rooms aren't [ __ ]
with if this is my studio if this is my
room I don't want flowery Fufu [ __ ] in
places that don't roll with my style
right so
you know like the idea of negotiating
every single room and saying nothing is
too trivial to attend to get everything
in its proper place
including toilet seats you know there's
always that argument oh he left it up
well I want it down well he can't leave
it up well they got to put it down you
know people argue over you know the most
trivial things and I've had guys calling
on my shows before and it's like my wife
yells at me because I leave the toilet
seat up and it's like who [ __ ] cares
right put it down like why are you
bothering me with this I'm chasing
Excellence I'm putting a dent in
Universe I'm doing something significant
with my life and you're bothering me
with a [ __ ] toilet seat right like I
wouldn't even get involved with a chick
that would bother me about [ __ ] like
that but there's guys that are telling
you
nothing is too trivial to attend to get
everything in its proper place and
negotiate how everything is going to be
because he says the alternative is
tyranny slavery or chaos
um okay you suggest give them what they
want and they will give you what you
want so
he's like yes he's like you know I say
yes to my wife uh what do you say he has
an agreement that if I can say yes to
you then I will
and it sounds to me like he says yes a
lot to a lot of things I remember there
was a stand-up comic I think it was
Chris Rock you talked about the yes
stamp he goes if you just get married
you just have to get a yes stamp just
say yes yes yes yes yes honey can we yes
can we do this yes can we yes and the
whole skit you know is about just being
a Yes Man
and
look you want to do the build a better
beta plan and March in the
slaughterhouse with your eyes closed and
hope everything works out for the best
more power to you but from what I've
seen and the people that I've talked to
in my experience and everything that
I've consumed
red pill unplugging Evo psych all this
[ __ ] okay taking a look at the Matrix
for what it really is
I don't think any of this stuff is that
useful I think he's got some good ideas
I like how he
deals with some of the craziness when it
comes to the wokism and you know like
the crazy conversations they have with
this guy like he does a very good job
dealing with a lot of society's [ __ ]
I I just don't see this series being
that useful to men when it comes to
contemplating divorce or sorry
contemplating contemplating marriage
because as we know it's probably going
to end in divorce uh and as he admitted
where was it
difficult custody battle is the
equivalent to a near fatal bet with
cancer so he knows what guys March into
um remember he used to do a lot of
therapy sessions with couples too
uh
spends a lot of time talking about
organizing the house with your wife
he also seems to yield a lot to Tammy
there was an example that I made a note
here of paintings he likes to collect
paintings
and apparently he's got a thing for dark
um Stalin era sort of paintings
um and you know look if you have a
studio or a study
um a library or something like that
there might be a place for that you know
place you like to work maybe it offers
an inspiration I don't nobody liked them
um but the way that he was talking about
the paintings and how they had to go
through the paintings and what they were
going to do when they were doing the
renovations with the house it just it
just sounded like a lot of yes yes yes
yes yes to you know to Tammy to give her
what she wanted
um which is just like whatever man you
know if that's what you want to do then
that's what you want to do if that
doesn't matter to you but
um I I really don't see the point I just
don't just just too small and too
trivial and too stupid and you might
want to call me what was the word that
he used for it uh
a tyrannical slave driver that's not his
words it's just
the definition expanded you get the idea
um he also made an interesting comment
in the third segment
uh and by the way he has some decent
advice with kids
um and the talk of negotiation in the
relationship would make sense
if you have somebody to negotiate with
that takes accountability and
responsibility
the vast majority of women today
don't take responsibility and
accountability a lot of guys don't
either by the way it's not just women a
lot of guys don't either it's always
somebody else's fault point and sputter
I'm the victim blah blah [ __ ] blah I
said in my red flag chapter
um one of the types of women that you
want to avoid are women that number two
on the list by the way which is feminist
and here I'm going to put up the
uh ticker for my email list because if
you haven't opted in
uh here it is so go to my email list if
you haven't opted in and you can get the
uh chapter 120 red flags for free but if
you deal with feminists
they have a victim mindset by default
and the vast majority of women today
whether they admit to it publicly or not
are in fact feminists you know Society
Culture The Matrix if you will has
contaminated their thinking in such a
way that they for the most part believe
that men make less sorry women make less
for the exact same job that men do
they're they're paid less this arguments
have been blown out of the water a
thousand times Jordan Peterson had a
great conversation
um with that BBC reporter about it and
just destroyed it
um but
you know using that as an example women
like to be victims and you can't
negotiate with somebody that has a
victim mindset and it's not
in the ethos of women it seems like it's
culturally
Infuse into their belief system today
um again you know
vote for more inclusivity for more
kindness for more bigger government for
more handouts for larger tax rates tax
are rich tax those [ __ ] tax
those guys and let's hand it out to
everybody else
um you can't negotiate with somebody
that has a victim mindset and
unfortunately a lot of women that you're
going to deal with today have that like
if you were to flat out say don't invite
somebody into your life that has a
victim mindset don't get married to
somebody that you can't
um have a conversation with they won't
take responsibility for things that they
do wrong
then I tip my hat to that but it's very
very difficult
for me to co-sign much of this based on
what I saw hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out